nothing worse than dry chapped lips
there you go
[Music]
gentlemen welcome to the office lancer
dermatology the first thing you see on
someone socially whether you're 5 feet
from number fifty feet away is their
facial complexion what do you do to take
care of your skin I've got a right 8 and
get some cocoa butter so penis Rodin in
their Soyuz aloof on your face with
liquid cocoa butter soap yeah right I
have my bar soap and I have my facial
soap wow that's very refined yes
that's sophisticated I like that guys
well good now we just want to polish it
up a little bit we're on earth naked
look even better well at least one of
you Ryan Seacrest and I came up with a
product line purely for male needs the
polished by Lancer is simple and it
works and after the first use you're
gonna see a huge difference let me
introduce you to Louise she's my
esthetician deluxe she does all the
celebrities I think we should get
started with this I mean ladies waiting
yeah I feel like like a celebrity
the first product the daily micro scrub
it has some ivory palm in it and it has
a whole variety of soft exfoliants or
things that gently remove the upper skin
cell layer you seem for people who have
a little bit of a scruff you'll find
that this polish keeps the pores around
the hair follicles unclogged I am
feeling the I feel the tingling
sensations
then it's rinsed down and then brushed
away and in the process the skins being
exercised and all the dead skin cell
debris is coming off and then she's
going to be using the dual cleansing
shave and it just uniformly cleanses the
skin way over 50 if you just picture
where you are now versus using bar soap
in the shower you see the difference
right yeah okay I'm sure and then after
you pat dry that's when you put on the
serum I feel the way she's putting it on
it's sort of like exercising it into the
skin
the oil-free moisturizer next now the
lip balm that's something you're not
used to it's a treat and you'll see that
the lips feel better you know you look
so good I think you can actually go back
to high school freshman year Wow Wow oh
my slowing I can have to blow yourself a
kiss you saw where I took you oh yeah we
talked about you me try a tip Olga
expensive your skin looks great you look
good to me we're both glowing yeah I
didn't I know you look any better
[Music]